joe's going to start off this hour in
boston hey joe what's up
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
so i'm uh 22 years old and graduating
college in a couple weeks
um i'll be getting married in the fall
my fiance will also
be graduating uh we're we're really
excited for that both of us
congratulations it's awesome man
thank you thank you so excited um we're
both debt-free
i'm going to be making about 45 000
after graduation
and she's probably gonna be in a similar
ballpark maybe
a little less but not that much um we
currently have about
20 25 000 in saving
which a good chunk actually comes from
the unemployment assistance and we're
just you know a little concerned about
that you know with some of the new
legislation
going forward is you know if we might
have to pay it back so we're trying to
figure out the
the best way to just make smart
decisions with you know an
apartment or um probably not buying a
house
but you know a living situation and just
uh how to be you know financially
responsible to live well going forward
way to go what's your degree in what's
her degree in
minds in theology hers is in psychology
and elementary education
okay so are you gonna become a pastor or
what are you gonna do
i'm going to be a youth minister at a
catholic church nearby in the area
wonderful good for you okay cool thank
you
very fun all right well uh you know
it sounds like you got a lot on your
plate uh it's gonna be an exciting 12
months agreed
yeah yeah absolutely we're very excited
so why boston man
uh just grew up here um you know big big
red sox fan big
awesome sports fan and you know we're
both
from the area and love it you know
playing playing to stay uh
around around here okay well buying a
home is a good thing
as a part of the scope of your life uh
it's a complicated thing it's a big
decision
uh there's a lot of moving parts to it
uh obviously it requires money it's
one of the largest purchases you'll ever
make in most cases
and uh so i recommend something that's
highly uncomfortable
because everybody's running around going
get a house get a house get a house get
a house because all renters go to hell
get a house get a house get a house get
a house right
you know it's like like renting is evil
or something you know what i'm saying
and i don't want you to be a renter when
you're 32
you're 22. okay but but i don't want you
to
add a house purchase to the busiest year
of your life ever
you're graduating getting new jobs
getting married
i mean my god the last thing you want to
do is hang curtain rods
yeah okay i mean really it causes
divorces but
um yeah so i we always joke and say
you'll make a
the serious thing is you'll make a
better decision one year after marriage
about which house to purchase
because you'll know each other better
you've got all of this busyness and
craziness in your rearview mirror
and it'll be a calm steady wise decision
you're out of debt you have your
emergency fund you have a good down
payment
that's a good decision i got to get a
house because i'm getting married
is about the way you make a stupid
mistake and by the way it takes about a
year of being married to know how close
to your mother-in-law to buy i was going
to say two or three years but
one's a minimum and maybe yeah i'd get
the smallest
the smallest place y'all can afford to
live in like
you're not trying to prove anything to
anybody you're getting each other that
was a mistake i made coming out of
colleges i rented this big freaking nice
place that was like three times more
expensive than i should
just because i could afford it and it
was all rented money it says wasted
money right
and i stayed there six months and then
we moved in the stinky butt little
apartment and started saving money
and we had bugs in our first apartment
man it was awesome
i'm not saying it was great i'm just
saying we should sign up
and we learned to have some
conversations that we wouldn't have had
yeah it's okay to go small and clean no
bucks
yeah yeah no rats you don't need any
pets in there just you too
just spend the year spend the year
enjoying your first year of marriage and
your first year of starting off at adult
life with all these jobs and graduations
and all this stuff
and you know and you will make a much
better decision a year later
and be out of debt have your emergency
fund and have your down payment and but
everybody's going to put pressure on you
because everybody's a freaking genius
you're 22 you're gonna die if you don't
buy a house horse crap you're not gonna
die
i've never considered um hitting you up
dave to create a dave ramsey t-shirt but
a t-shirt that said all runners go to
hell would sell
really well that's a fantastic but isn't
it the way people talk about it oh
they talk about it as if it's a
salvation issue the number of people
when we just got an apartment
i didn't i didn't know what we were
doing with our livestream they sound
like a beagle chasing a rabbit
oh you're just gonna if you want you
could all just go flush your money for
you i mean i
it was over and over and over yeah and
they're all they're all broke
but they all got expert advice on me
buying a house yes that's right
you know it's just they're just and they
do they they drive
peop you people you broke people don't
need to be giving financial advice
it makes you look dumb and god help you
somebody will follow it
and just set a young couple up to be
stable
and you said it best the last thing a
young couple needs taking two new jobs
in a new town
and a new marriage is to also be
worrying about can we make this rent
payment or this this mortgage payment
this month or what's our house worth or
the plumbing broke or that whatever
happens with new houses which it always
happens
you know in in ancient times the second
kings in the bible even
when a young couple got married it's
very clear
that the brand new husband did not go
out to war
in the first year he stayed home to make
a home with his wife
they didn't put brand new married
soldiers on the front lines
in ancient israel you need to get
because he knows if he goes out there
and you know he's not going to make good
decisions he's not going to make good
decisions
yeah and it's very interesting there's
something about that first year of
marriage i mean you probably know some
research on the statistics of
you know what you invest in each other
in the first year of marriage
sets a pattern for the rest of your life
that's the key is
these patterns that you adopt really
quick and it can take
years to unwind and they happen
overnight right yeah
you're both bringing you're both
bringing your old patterns into this one
pattern and you set it real fast
it takes a while to undo those things
you say or those things you do or those
annoying
man you've got to really unlearn all
that spend your time getting to know
each other here's the other thing
when you say when you do give somebody
good advice they remember it i remember
sharing i've been married almost 40
years we got married and we moved into
this too expensive a house
and it was three it was four bedrooms it
was two of us two dogs
it was ridiculous but it was nice yeah
you know we thought we we thought we
were
you know pretty cool and i went back i
stopped by and saw my old
uh elementary school principal evelyn
hyde
and she's like where are you living i
told her and i was like all proud and
she's like
that's dumb
[Laughter]
she's she's the best that's the best
dude the world needs more evelyn's yes
they do to look at
genius 22 year olds and say that's dumb
that was dumb